for minecraft youtuber and speedrunner
dream 2020 was a wild
ride he gained 15 million subs was named
youtube's breakout star of the year
and collaborated with the likes of mr
beast and corp's husband
but he was also accused of cheating by
multiple people
he got doxxed after doing a weird neck
reveal
and he hired a harvard trained
astrophysicist
to write his defense paper against those
cheating allegations
and apparently it's full of holes like i
said quite the year
guys 2021 is the year that the score
esports hits
2 million subscribers we're well on our
way but we need your help
so if you haven't already scroll down
and hit that subscribe button for me
if you do maybe my parents will finally
understand what the hell it is i do for
a living all right this
dream being accused of cheating story is
really complicated so
strap in in 2020 this dude was
everywhere
from his minecraft videos to making
guest appearances on other channels
dreams oddly creepy logo
is burned into my brain he's known for
speedrunning minecraft and has a history
of setting and breaking records for
websites like speedrunning.com
alright now i need to get into some
super specific
minecraft speedrunning [ __ ] so bear with
me
the type of speed running that dream is
known for is referred to as
any percent random seed glitchless which
basically means
it's hard as [ __ ] instead of speed
running the same world or seed
every time where you can trial and error
your way to victory
any percent random seek glitch list
gives you a new world that is completely
unpredictable
every single time on top of that glitch
list obviously means you can't
manipulate or glitch your way to a fast
time and dream is really good at it
yes oh my god is it time you have 18
seconds
get in
yes now in minecraft speedrunning a
common goal
and way to stop the clock is by
defeating the ender dragon in order to
do that you have to activate an end
portal and step through it in order to
activate one of those
you need a bunch of ender pearls making
them a crucial resource on each run
the catches and or pearls are really
difficult to come by
a common way to get them is to barter
with these weird pig creatures called
piglins
every time you barter with them you have
a tiny chance of getting a pearl drop
and back in october people in the
minecraft scene started asking
questions about the rate in which dream
was getting these pearl drops
see dream was getting pearl drops at an
astronomically high rate
a rate that led youtubers like shell guy
and video game dunky
to publish videos accusing dream of
cheating across recent speedruns he had
streamed on twitch
and based on the small amount of data
that the minecraft scene had collected
plus a handful of dream streams to scrub
through
and the minecraft speedrunning moderator
team decided to dig a little deeper
see speedrunning.com keeps track of the
various times and records of each game
on the site
and each game has a team of mostly
volunteer moderators and minecraft
is no different now i interviewed the
head of the minecraft speedrunning mod
team a guy named geosquared
and here's what he had to say about the
initial allegations
so on october 16th there was this um
uh pretty well respected runner in the
in the game
he had uh several world records
previously he posted some data
that suggested that the rates were like
ridiculously high considerably so
so we just looked at the math it was
sort of a novelty for a second
but then the real reality of um the fact
that you know somebody the size of dream
might have tampered with stuff sort of
set in probably on you know october 16th
right around there and keep in mind the
mod team wouldn't just be evaluating a
single wonky run that dream had
submitted
they'd be looking at 24 hours of runs
from across
six different twitch streams while they
got busy with their investigation
dream published a 10-page response
basically refuting all of the
allegations
and claiming that people were just
cherry-picking data to make him look bad
but then almost two months later on
december 11th
as dream's wildly successful year was
coming to a close
a 29-page investigation into dream
allegedly cheating
was published by geo in the minecraft
speedrunning mod team
geo also published a youtube video on
behalf of the moderator team
basically explaining the process behind
the investigation
as well as giving his thoughts on the
situation as a whole
so the minecraft speedrun moderation
team in a combined effort with
mathematical experts in our community
have launched an investigation which is
culminating in the release of this video
and a statistical analysis paper that
thoroughly examines the case and
accounts for bias
it's important to note that as a
consequence of this investigation and
the youtube video
dreams best time that he submitted over
the course of the runs that were being
investigated
was stripped from the minecraft
leaderboards now the 29-page paper and
the youtube video are a long
and short dive into the probability and
statistics
surrounding the incredible rate at which
dream was getting these pearl drops
and while 42 pearls which is the number
that dream ended up with
might not seem like a lot apparently in
this situation
it's insanely high dream getting an
astounding 42 successful trades
out of 262 possible trades these results
are exceptional
as they are not only substantially
greater than their expected values
but perhaps more notably substantially
greater than the rates from other top
level runners and according to all of
the math that the speed running mod team
did
factoring in a host of different
variables the chances of dream getting
the drops that he did
are 0.0000804 percent
or 201 out of 250 million
on top of that there's another item
called a blaze rod which are also super
useful and rare
and the odds at which dream was getting
those drops was 59
out of 1.25 trillion or 0.000000472
percent
and here's what geo had to say when i
asked him about what the team was hoping
to achieve with this investigation
we wanted to inform the public because
we knew that dream's response was coming
and we wanted to balance keeping it a
low profile
with also making sure that if people
learn about it they learn about the
correct information after the paper in
the video went out dream tweeted that
geo's video was click bait nonsense and
that the investigation was full of bias
from there dream took issue with a
portion of geo's video
where the speed running mods accused
dream of tampering with his mod folders
see
in the video dream is accused of using
some sort of mod or hack
buried deep in some hidden folder but
the most likely scenario is that dream
used some mod or data pack behind the
scenes in such a way that would be
undetectable to a naive viewer
this becomes a bit more suspicious when
you consider that dream was using fabric
which is a mod loader that a lot of the
community uses for performance increases
the stream for his mods folder
specifically so we could check for any
modification but he was unable to
provide any evidence since he says he
deletes the contents of his mods folder
pretty regularly dream fired back on
twitter saying that he had shared the
mods on all his files and he also
accused geo of lying
he then made the world or seed file in
question
public for anyone to inspect from there
dream said he was working on a response
video and then
apologized to the mod team for acting
like a baby
geo even asked fans to stop sending
dream hate
now i know i've thrown a lot of
information at you and i wish that the
story ended here but it doesn't
because on december 23rd dream posted a
24 minute response video
as well as a 10-page report that was
apparently written by a harvard
educated astrophysicist that dream hired
to help with his defense
after reaching out to this expert he
insisted that if he was going to do this
analysis
that i must agree to release his
findings regardless of if they made me
look good or they made me look bad
knowing that i'm innocent i agreed now
the fact that he hired an astrophysicist
to defend himself from some true goobers
is some
top level trolling but the report didn't
land
exactly the way dream intended it to
because shortly after it went live an
alleged particle physicist with a phd in
physics
started picking the paper apart as did
other alleged scientists and
mathematicians
i wish i could say i was surprised that
a bunch of scientists started dunking on
dream on reddit
but it's read it so i'm not now i'm not
gonna go
through the whole 10-page paper but
there are a few things worth mentioning
one thing i think needs to be made clear
is that right off the bat this
astrophysicist
basically says hey guys just a heads up
this math [ __ ] is really hard and
there's no definitive answers
quote probability calculations are hard
there may not be one
right way to do something it is easy to
violate some hidden
or unknown assumption there is room for
healthy debate about different methods
and results
end quote also and this is important he
doesn't say that dream didn't cheat
quote one alternative explanation is
that dream
intentionally or unintentionally cheated
though i disagree that the situation
suggests that this is an unavoidable
conclusion
in any case the conclusion of the mst
report that there is
at best a one in 7.5 trillion chance
that dream did not cheat
is too extreme for multiple reasons that
have been discussed
in this document end quote what he's
saying there is that the odds presented
by the minecraft speedrunning mod team
are extremely high unlikely and should
be lower
but as to whether or not dream modified
his game and potentially
cheated the astrophysicist is basically
saying
i got no idea and this is important so
keep in mind for later and then on
december 30th a few days after dream
posted his video an astrophysicist's
written response
the moderator team rejected both of them
now at this point you might be thinking
december 30th did dream
start the new year on the right foot the
answer to that question is no
no he didn't because on january 2nd
dream was allegedly
doxed after posting photos of his
kitchen to twitter
see part of dream's shtick is the fact
that he's never showed his face on
camera
apparently this doxxing incident came
after the fact that he told fans he was
going to reveal his face
but he never did instead he revealed
part of his neck which ended up trending
on twitter
but let's get back to the unanswered
question on hand
did dream cheat here's what geo has to
say about that
i don't think we can ever know the exact
methodology
because i mean there are i mean a
million and one ways to do it
he can you can provide all these counter
examples of hey i didn't do it this way
it's like showing murder weapons that
you know weren't used
in the crime it's like oh of course i
didn't use like this knife in my
cabinet at the end of the day like we're
not able to know
but uh we are pretty confident based on
the you know publicly available
information
and the astrophysicists that dream hired
to write his original paper
who a lot of people thought didn't exist
by the way put out a response paper to
all of the people pointing out the
errors in his work
he hits back at some critics while
acknowledging some of the mistakes that
people
rightfully pointed out and remember how
i said that he never
claimed that dream didn't cheat in his
original paper
quote anyone who claimed that i said
dream did not cheat
was severely misrepresenting what i
wrote end quote
and here's how he concludes the response
to the response to the response
quote while some of the issues of the
minecraft speedrunning team response to
my original critique were
valid i disagree with their assessment
on others
after concluding their considerations
especially of the number of speedrunners
to compare to
i reevaluate the odds from 1 in 10
million to about 1 in 100 million
and still think that an upper board of 1
in 7.5
trillion is too strong but either way
the probabilities were almost certainly
modified and this provides
very strong evidence that dream cheated
now as far as dream is concerned he
recently tweeted out
that he's done arguing so what do you
think did he cheat
did he not cheat does any of this
[ __ ] matter let us know in the
comments below
tell this to tell your [ __ ] insane
story that only happens to you to the
stream
all right audience typically i get up
around seven o'clock every morning
because i'm a piece of
i'm a piece so i get up early right
today my alarm doesn't go off but i wake
up naturally i'm like that's kind of
weird but whatever
i'm up i got energy let's get this
started i feed the dog
i let her outside i take a shower i make
some coffee
all is right in the world i'm about to
start my day and then i look outside and
it's still
extremely dark out and at this point in
my morning routine it's not dark out and
so now i'm asking like
what the [ __ ] is going on here i uh then
double check the clock and it's two
o'clock in the morning
so um my dumb ass just went back to bed
god you are dumb and uh yeah that's how
i started my day today
so uh let me know let me know how you're
doing in the comments below